[Music]
hello welcome back to honest trailer
commentaries we're gonna be talking
about the honest trailer today that just
came out for Indiana Jones one two and
three the only Indiana Jones movies they
ever made if you watch the end you'll
get some deleted scenes will respond to
comments from viewers like you and piece
next week's honest trailer but first a
warm welcome making his appearance on
our little Brady Bunch I think for the
first time since we all went into our
holes it's la la la I first time from my
living room from your film dojo I love
it yeah well we've missed you and I'm
sure the people have missed all of our
thoughts on all the things honest
trailer so let's open up with Indiana
Jones no one's ever talked about these
movies before yeah they're good they're
pretty good there's some jokes to be had
what's here what are your indy thoughts
lon
i mean i love these movies they were
like real formative movies for me like i
Last Crusade I saw was the first one I
saw in the theater it was a big deal
because I'd already come to love the
other two so yeah I have a lot of like
nostalgic attachment I was a late like
Temple of Doom defenders like eventually
I have now come around to like
recognizing some of the flaws but I made
it through a bunch of my life is like
the last dumb white guy in the room be
like it's not that bad Danyelle
viscerally grimace what's the because I
was also I saw like the Temple of Doom
was my Indiana Jones um so I was also
one of the last people in the room to
defend that movie uh it should not be
defended but who who it was in the same
way that I have seen everything the
second first or last that was my one so
one you were not alone okay I was there
with you being
this piece of uh defending something
that should not have been defended man
but like it was well yeah it's gonna say
like can you watch that movie and go as
I did wow this one's really racist and
offensive and yet it's the most like
it's like a nightmarish fever dream so
it's like a fascinating watch to me
about being like wow Spielberg and Lucas
making movie about child slaves like
this is crazy
still wants to compartmentalize like
there are some amazing set pieces in
that movie like everything a club
obi-wan at the beginning and then the
escape from the plane and the rafted and
the the mine car yeah it's also though
it's also not a very it's let's just go
say yeah that's not very good movie but
it's because stops me from liking some
things yeah exactly it's not our stuff
people from liking one but I do think
that all the characters weirdly get
flattened like they turned into like
even indie and obviously like Willie
Scott like they turn into tropes like it
is like they ripped pages out of an old
cereal and then decided to film them and
in that case it is just like a weird
living nightmare that you get to watch
and I think that's interesting and the
monkey brains are terrible and there was
so much about this that is a god-awful
but I do I it was my first Indy Jeff
like Indiana Jones I saw it when I was
like I don't know man definitely less
than ten um so I always have like a
place in my heart where I go like you're
awful and terrible it's the reason we
have a pg-13 rating right it is it was
not the one that like after that like we
need we need something I actually in PD
please don't take out hearts the dinner
yeah get rid get rid of that dinner and
it's a movie we'll never know what it's
about
Joe's been cancelled all right let's uh
he'll come back about the the set-piece
thing about the characters being sort of
flattened like what I was saying happens
in Last Crusade to where everything kind
of the comedy gets sort of turned up to
11 it doesn't have that father-son bond
that's like emotional in the movie that
you didn't have any any relationship
like that even the Mindy Marion one that
was like explored throughout the whole
film like it wasn't Last Crusade well
it's also I'm going to be fair with with
one exception he was banging all of
those people but wait who was banging
hillocks Indy like he was I mean he was
banging all those people you know yes
except for his father yeah well but they
came as close as you can via via the
another trope that hasn't really made
its way into the later decades is the
hot Nazi sort of has hotties on the rise
done TV these days there's I guess you
have it like press secretaries well
there I'm sure there'll be more Nazi
talk as we watch the honest trailer for
Indiana Jones 1 2 3 and on my new
podcast NECA music this summer we're
getting honest about summer blockbusters
past and present this is honest trailers
blockbusters summer
from two dudes who built your childhood
by riffing on the stuff that built their
childhood
these visionaries at the height of their
powers will collaborate to achieve the
impossible make a guy look cool in a
fedora m'lady mas the Indian age I would
just like to give a warm fu to whoever
put the fedora on me I did not have that
hat on there was no consent
I don't own a fedora the closest I've
come is tricking my dad into thinking of
Fedora was cool that was a funny day we
uh he's like does this look good I'm
like yeah the end that day he got a
fedora but yeah I guess watching Perry
Mason want to he see he's doing he's
Fodor work wasn't true true it might be
a trio be I'm not good at the difference
between the old-timey hat but it is he's
like one of the very few other
characters I see there's like okay he's
really he's also doing a thing where he
ties his tie is really short and he
leaves the back part of the tie like he
doesn't tuck it in so he's got like a
split tie and it's real short and yeah
that would look ridiculous today but it
works well the problem with the fedora
is that it's the people who wear fedoras
never fully commit the Fedora is an
accessory it's the cherry on top of the
sundae you have to be wearing an entire
outfit from that era you need to be
dressed like a grave robbing
archaeologist or like you're on your way
to or from a racetrack like you can't
wear you know your and you have to talk
old-timey and you have to kind of talk
old-timey yeah you can't have your wife
my 50 shirt and your and your basketball
shorts and then put a fedora on it and
you're like instant class it
if you haven't inherited your
great-grandfather's leather jacket you
also can't wear a fedora yeah yeah I
mean if you see that the entire outfit
has to be geared to support a fedora
it's like the capstone to the arch you
know also I'd like to apologize I spoke
briefly with my PR team and I'd like to
issue a public apology for us we'll be
getting a screen shot of a notes app
there's nothing I love more than iOS
press release sorry I was our zoom
meeting right before this and my
computer was like I hate the internet
and computer was right fair enough
just looking away through router out of
the wall let him talk about wanting to
be short round when he was little that's
it we don't support the Thuggee cult no
fedora m'lady the Indiana Jones trilogy
prepared for three near-perfect
adventure movies Raiders of the Lost Ark
a film that's perfect in every way
except when it implies the heroes up
with a child I was a child I like yeah
man it's like wasn't the original idea
that she was gonna be like 11 or
something crazy I think when they were
but I think that I think the first days
like it's either Spielberg Lucas that
says 12 and then it like gradually
creeps up to like 15 16 one of them said
and we show the screen shot in a minute
but it was like after 15 it's not
interests that would be George Lucas you
know what
[Laughter]
whoa cuffs to point out that maybe it's
bad that the hero of your story banged a
15 year old girl
I mean Miriam gets the the Ross deal in
in film because Angie zaps like didn't
it like it likes screwed with her family
and like her her dad like just some [ __ ]
to basically run away to like start a
bar in the Himalayas that indie that
shows back up if it burns down he's like
the answer like he's really ruined her
entire life for sure yeah yeah Indiana
Jones rolled up in DePaul and was like
hey I'd really like to talk about that
thing for my for me yeah I mean it's
really like he needs a thing that she
has that he doesn't like it doesn't even
end up anyway and then he shows up when
they're like in their 60s and marries
her yeah like he won't leave this poor
woman alone yeah it's not great overall
deal yeah you don't lose anything by
making her of age don't lose anything by
making your page I think it's the most
important part yeah really bizarre cuz
when you watch the movie like it's
perfectly easy to imagine she's you to
speak sort of metaphor like I was a
child meaning like I was a lot younger
than you
it was I call everyone under 24 hour
child yes that is how I used to imagine
it before we got this very dark and
unpleasant story about white which we
will get into later absolute creeps but
uh yeah all right let's do Templar do a
film that's perfect in every way
except for all the racism and the Last
Crusade lost Joan that is perfect in
every way as the ending to this hero's
journey except for the fact that it
wasn't
and it still isn't let the man rest
he's already to over this been Raiders
it's the mortgage he can't even get it
up for an interview these days who shot
first greed overhung I don't care
Harrison four stars has done I want them
to keep making big-budget movies with
Harrison Ford just so we can keep
getting these press tours because I do
think that they're the most charming
things he's done in decades his contempt
for junkets but is such an interesting
contrast of him Bruce's Bruce Willis
like Bruce Willis has this like he's
also bored by being a movie star and
doesn't like anymore but he has this
really sour to meet her about it
whereas Harrison Ford is just kind of
like aloof and above it all but it's
really charming instead yeah he's even
though he's saying all of this stuff is
made-up stop asking me about it like
he's very charming and comfortable in
his own skin
whereas Bruce Willis does I'm like he he
wants to murder the person asking the
question he's mad at us for liking him
still yes but they were notoriously
Rihanna had a plane where she invited
all the press on it oh and then she hid
do a Harrison Ford plane where he's
flying the plane
and that is how you interview him for
junkets are you trying to say that then
Harrison crashes and kills all the
journalists what are you trying to set
up here rats there's some type of money
plane this keeps coming up over the last
few days we're talking about the
spiritual sequel to Indiana Jones in the
Last Crusade money plane starring Kelsey
Grammer and work where can the people
find money playing these days I don't
know
we don't know you screen okay we don't
in the sky all right yes Kiko why isn't
killing grammar in more terrible movies
like he feels like he should have a log
its story but it's just like down
periscope now this one hmm I feel like I
need like 20 more terrible Kelsey
Grammer VOD so really are them and I
just haven't looked I'm sure people will
send me links down Harrison Ford stars
as doctor Indiana Jones
he's not just a terrible professor
he's also a terrible archaeologist and a
tomb of Sir Richard you saw him
well what was left of him who discovers
temple is that what completely changed
the way we think about ancient cultures
then rubs their ass blind and turns them
into rubble I read a bunch of articles
about life what archaeologists think
about Indiana Jones and like here's the
things Indiana Jones gets wrong about
archaeology I'm sorry archaeology so
boring this movie if these movies were
three hours about like slowly brushing
off a bone
yeah we have to watch it the handle of a
vase I spent like 12 hours softly
feather dusting this with this base
handle and now it would be Indiana Jones
directed by Lake Verna Hertzog like like
an art film like Andy Warhol or
something would just like shoot a
feather duster on a bone for 12 hours
and call it archaeology because he's not
doing archaeology's when Indiana Jones
is doing obviously he's robbing he's not
studying he's robbing he's a grave
robber but that's why I didn't like it
it's sheep but we like it he's like he's
like a treasure hunter baby probably
like the jobs like a job no one has ever
really had but that has the most movies
about it
oh yeah of all the all the fictional
jobs of all time treasure hunters gotta
be oh when I got when I got caught
shoplifting in middle school and told
the security guards I was a treasure
hunter that it didn't fly they still
called my dad bill paxton in Titanic
cage in the national treasure bones but
I will just say about like Lara Croft
Tomb Raider
yeah but Kara's already rich that's why
she could do this the character of
Indiana is he's cool but it's not like I
do think that he's supposed to be
bumbling like he's not presented as
not good like we saw later as James Bond
or as like a like a not a traditional
action hero but yeah like it like a
Schwarzenegger character like he's
getting in over his own head he's
winging it and the great American
fantasies that will always come out on
top if we do that if we just come and
smash a bunch of stuff everything will
be fine in the end we're all cops
yeah totally right he's a much more
subtle Jack Burton yeah yeah exactly
the first action well not the first
action scene in Raiders but like as soon
as you get as soon as the Nazi show up
in Nepal
the first thing he does is accidentally
set the bar on fire it's the first thing
he does he's kind of like a dog hero
like you know the new version of Philip
Marlowe he used to be the like super
cool elite Private Eye and now it's
Elliott Gould
it's like I think they kind of took that
back sort of idea like we seemed like
the big lebowski kinda inherits that and
I put it in these old so usually the
adventure hero would be like you know
Tarzan or whatever like this Superman
kind of character and now it's this more
like contemporary like he's bumbling
through you know he's getting by to me
the seem that sums it up is the guy with
the scimitar and then he's like oh I can
just shoot this guy I don't have to be
yeah which was caused by some kind of
illness I didn't want to do the fight
scene and crew you know constraints bred
creativity and or my all-time favorite
Indiana Jones moment which is an Indiana
Jones and the Temple of Doom when he
realizes he's gotten himself surrounded
on a bridge and just looks to his left
looks to his right sighs and says oh
[ __ ] like that's that's some smile yeah
yeah yeah but he gets out anyways and
gets everything you wanted relatability
[Music]
he's a cropped up in booty shorts away
from being a Tomb Raider but Indies not
alone along for the ride is his high
school crush Marion as in she was in
high school while he was pushing 30 pots
and alcohol I feel the same way about
that story conference that I do about
Temple of Doom where you look at this
you look at that and you're like this is
horrible what their psyche is making a
girl younger and younger for the hero to
have sex with up setting that aside and
now that's a big thing to set aside this
is like the most fascinating thing I've
ever read it's George Lucas Steven
Spielberg and Lawrence Kasdan just
coming up with Indiana Jones so like as
just a way of like the creative process
and how movies are made I recommend
everybody read this and just like during
some parts but I think it's such an
amazing thing that it's online for free
and so I'm gonna do a thing which I
agree with you spending spending um
there is I think it's a an onion AV Club
article which is called the Ewok theory
which is about how women and people of
color and queer folks often have to view
media where it's like you know you love
the Star Wars
you love rich Jedi but you hate the
Ewoks so you just ignore them and that's
how sometimes you just got to do what
stuff that's like problematic and crappy
when it's old you love the thing and yet
you just have to ignore the other stuff
um you love indie you hate that a pork
the fifteen-year-old yes there's a few
things you have to hold in your mind at
the same time otherwise you lose your
you'll go insane in modern society there
is a great article about that and that
is literally you know the life that a
lot of us live but you walk theories so
it's called see us I think but yet I
read that it is genuinely I think like
it that's what we do I you read an
article like that which is incredibly
fascinating in you're right about these
two amazing filmmakers making something
like
jerry and then you know you get to that
part where they're like maybe we make
her 11 new like because the second one
general doom is particularly influenced
by ganga did which is this class say 30s
adventure movie which is horrific lira
days i mean we're talking about a temple
of to this to this leg it makes like
some crazy builds fool is very
influential sort of all future kind of
adventure movies at battle genre and and
before i watched it in film class we
basically talked about what's now being
a you know Ewok theory which is like
look there's stuff you got to know about
the way this movie was made but like
please know that we know it's like
horrible you know all of the indian kid
you know senton raj india during British
colonial rule and it's like the British
people get to act like adults and all of
these people are treated like basically
grown children and it's discussed and it
is just back to the transcript like a
fascinating look into just the instincts
I guess of Spielberg and Lucas and
Kasdan and Spielberg is constantly
trying to bring it back to like a
character place and what if he whips the
guy in the pants and his pants fall down
[Laughter]
like like he's coming up with for
Raiders that he finally got to use it in
Temple of Doom he like wanted to do the
like they all fly out of a plane on a
life raft can they do this big toboggan
sequence like and then they hit a guy in
the pants pants well yeah that's the
things like it's the it's the melding of
like that the cartoonish meanness with
some heart that that makes his movies
great yeah
all right let's give Indy beats his new
guide he's a fish alien who talks like
he's from the Caribbean goal while he
was pushing 30 and alcoholic who's just
as tough and smart as Indiana and she's
captured
and she's captured again and guess what
that's right
captured the not so lovely Willie Scott
that's more food than these people eat
in a week I'm not hungry
who screamed her way through the entire
sequel and into the directors heart we
have so much in common
she hates bugs and I find that
entertaining and Shawna zoo robust how
dare you not respect on Willie Scott's
name
I like this carrot not everybody was
born to go on an adventure with Indiana
Jones Willie nice lady who just wanted
to sing in a nightclub and make her
money and like deta in like a murdering
criminal like she was married to the mob
and I think maybe that's why I like this
is my first Indiana Jones
I loved Romancing the stone and it was
very romantic own for me um like it had
that more racist um but it had like that
vibe for me so I think that that's why I
liked it so much I think if this crew
loves Ruby rhod
you gotta love Willie Scott Willie Scott
screamed so that Ruby rhod kids dream
[Laughter]
it's one of those times where I feel
like you do have to you like it's an
accurate nod to the source material I
think there are a lot of characters like
that excuse me in thirties movies and
for teaspoons and adventure serious the
like gun Moll who's screaming and
yelling all the time is nervous like it
makes sense in that way it's just a bit
much and look we weren't doing the
medicine that we were doing now and like
when they tried to do it in other movies
we didn't like them we didn't like
movies that did that so this came as
close to like meta and whatever is you
could get I just think a little of that
goes a longer way like she was so she
never had that moment where she like you
know ties her shirt off and like rolls
up her sleeves and is like okay I get
the situation where it well she has to
crack off her heels and then you know
she has to crack
yeah you never cracked off those heels
in look everyone cracks off the heels
aw Romancing the Stone you crack off
them heels and the Jurassic Park series
the new one you crack off them eels you
got a crack them heels oh and then we
know that women are people yeah I guess
it just read writing book that's your
save the cat is cracked the video they
should for me though it was like their
romance did not make a lick of sense
like she was but she was a lady and he
was a man so they have to smooch senses
Keanu and Sandra and speed they're like
this is a crazy situation you know this
isn't gonna last and it didn't because
she went on that cruise alone Patrick
yeah
and she was also like I don't know how
this always happens to me but I think
this is a good old less of a romance and
more of a we just our Adrenaline's
really high and we're both very
attractive yeah and this is a prequel so
it didn't last because otherwise she'd
be in a Raiders it would have lasted if
she was 11 dog okay all right keep going
and Sean Connery in a dual role as both
Indiana's father and his K brother
sutanu Schmidt come on guys Sean Connery
at sex is not a twist enter a mr. cool
he was he was voted sexiest man of the
century Sean Connery so props there
century country
what time is Sean Connery arrived at
Wimbledon you guys what time Tennis West
enter a mystical world where Judaism is
real an offensive version of Hinduism is
real and Christianity is real
but the hero is an atheist I don't
believe in magic a lot of superstitious
hocus-pocus man ignoring the
supernatural is kind of Harrison Ford's
thing hokey religions and ancient
weapons are no match for a good blaster
at your side kid and [ __ ] the globe on
these non-stop thrill rides determined
to give you every possible combo of
action man versus man car versus car
cards versus cars bike versus bike boat
vs. boat horse versus truck horse versus
train horse versus tank plane versus
playing playing versus car plane versus
bird man versus larger man man first
British man first all Member State
kippers kid goes first man members car
and man versus a scene after scene of
masterfully directed set pieces with
real characters stakes and clarity of
movement that today's filmmakers took
one look at and went not too hard let's
just fill the screen with a bunch of CGI
puke
it'll be toe including Lucas and
Spielberg
but there were more variations of action
sequences I think what struck me
rewatching miss is like I know it's
silly because their adventure in action
movies but like 80% of these movies are
set pieces in action like they cram so
much character and plot into they weave
it in into some really quick scenes
because so much the movie is them
running around I was shocked in it and
it's a it's beautiful man it's beautiful
they you know where everything is and I
know that's a weird thing to like I know
it's like some old band stuff but it
also like there are plenty of old movies
that feel incredibly slow and you're
bored watching the what passed for
action back then but these are cut like
like modern films and they're all real
and they're all excellent in that regard
and it's so sad to see what they've what
they've done to my boy like they're all
like it's not it's not like one I was
recently real watching the pirates
movies and a lot of great action scenes
in those two but in every action
sequences like 20 minutes long and like
by the end you like lose track of where
you even were when you started or what
was even going on and these are like
it's it's efficient to like the minecart
chase goes on for a long time but a lot
of these are like it's a few minutes of
just like really it's cool action and
then it's resolved you're on to the next
location and it's not just punching like
you've learned things about the
characters by the way they punch or the
way they fight ah it's not just you know
random legs and stuff yeah there's a
progression like there's a there's like
an act 1 act 2 act 3 of like the truck
chasin Raiders like it has it's like a
miniature movie in itself more lady
hurricanrana thoughts well we know
you're a lady them can fight if you
can't
and then temple doom props I do think
that the dance sequence is actually
incredible that opens the movie like
that's really cool that was always
wanted to do a musical and that was his
like little excuse to work a musical set
pieces or one of his movies which will
now you know now West Side Story will
finally get to immature
to realize the street there you go
alright let's keep going so enjoy a
franchise that's the American answer to
James Bond where instead of being suave
cool and efficient he keeps getting his
cover blown the fuel a Scottish sloth
I am Mickey Mouse getting robbed this
time it will cost you what was briefly
yours is now mine you give me the
diamond this is the second time I've
have to reclaim my property from you
gets caught bluffing all the time Suzy
will doesn't have any real impact on
what happens in his own movie and makes
it pretty clear you either die a hero or
live long enough to be the bad guy in a
black panther movie how do you think
your ancestors got these stories on
which I would I would watch by the way
longer verse indie yes right now the the
doesn't have any impact is is of course
the the famous like Raiders Theory where
if you remove Indiana Jones but I think
all of that ties into what we've been
talking about with the fact that he's
like he's doing his best he's kind of
like tripping on his own feet and
accidentally setting things on fire and
doing his best whereas it's I mean let's
take the Jack Burton comparison it's the
same yeah yeah yeah and I was just gonna
say up top is that this idea came about
when Spielberg's
was talking Lucas about how he wanted to
make a James Bond movie which I think
would have been very interesting but
Lucas was like well I've got an idea for
you hold on your hat Indiana Smith which
was his name until the first day of
shooting I don't know why they changed
it but it was all pitched and and gonna
go as Indiana Smith took from the quote
Men in Tights it's a good change there
you go first he was like I got an idea
it's about a duck who plays guitar that
he ends up in Cleveland
okay let's wrap it up starring story
antica jones out of control Karen caught
on video
Sallah the old young Indiana Jones
chronicles I don't know why Belloc
swallow that fly Big Willie style screw
mutt
this is Indy son finish him fatality
just let it go Elsa Elsa dan aykroyd
Miracle Whip
[Music]
hitting Nazis good hitting women and
children bad hitting Sean Connery and
open-handed Shrivers justified know what
that is in reference to it's a famous
it's probably with Playboy but then he
got asked about it on Barbara Walters or
something like that
the famous clip is Barbara Walters
asking him about it yeah like do you
really think it's Oh Davis lap women and
he's like ash sometimes they just push
your too far it's a really tough and
women what's that yeah he says with an
open part ball sometimes they put you
too far yeah not is not imagine if that
happened today this is back on funny
everybody
rest in peace corn pop there you go for
children that's that reference all right
keep on the drivers justified and
Harrison Ford in real life
crashing planes
vacation you're towing alright pause so
apparently we're getting some flak in
the comments because we've also called
Princess Bride Adventure Time and that's
whoops that is a mistake
that's our bad I'm not gonna say who I'm
throwing under the bus but it's it's not
my fault because two two of the four
people here wrote that they like the
title Adventure Time and I'm nothing if
not gracious I let the majority rule so
the this is where we are I think we'll
get to the alts and realized what we
should have picked but that's that's our
bad I liked it and in fairness to me I
was not writing on his trailers yet when
you guys did Princess Bride no and I
don't watch anything that I don't write
yeah that's that my question i absolve
myself because no one listens to me
anyway that is true alright let's let's
get to this tag and deleted scene see
what we shoulda picked aim actors are
always shorter than you think but they
said that stab is exactly five feet tall
Oh cute little guy there you go strong
manly representation in Indiana Jones
whatever here on that one too and so I
hope to pull back the curtain we did a
lot of research on that one to found a
lot of different articles well how big a
Kadam is is in real life is at
interpretation or not a privilege is
something but in the movie they say six
Kadam like 72 inches divide that by 12
you you know but if it's five Kadam I
don't know I can't do math trust me it's
five feet according to the movie not
according to actual Kadam all right
let's see some deleted scenes house
really stuff going to archaeology
because you love the films it's been
your entire life playing operation with
a feather duster come on he's a grave
robber pure and simple I mean the guy
stole the name of his own dog
named the dog Indiana and his K brother
sinto cuishle whoa did not see that
coming han makes it pretty clear the
world would be a better
you
and we're back
various culprits for this include Joe's
cat Danielle's cat blonds dog and my
baby who pulled the plug you be the
judge so yeah we were about to get into
the end of the deleted scenes let's just
keep playing those let's really suck to
go into archeology because you love the
film's then spend your entire life
playing operation with a feather duster
come on he's a grave robber pure and
simple I mean the guy stole the name of
his own dog were named the dog Indiana
and his K brother isn't old cuishle whoa
did not see that coming man makes it
pretty clear the world would be a better
place if he never existed yeah yeah he
rescues those kids but Indy had didn't
ban child labour to the 50s there's
going back to their old jobs story the
chat in the hatch Harry old man the
prisoner bar rescue 1001 Arabian slides
him Lee PEZ dispenser
Phoenix Indiana whippersnapper arc
reactor
the French erection scream queen Willie
or won't II thuggy life Bram scary in
the heart tasters pray obeyed and when a
problem comes along indy whips it
Indiana Jones the grave robber who named
himself after his dog that should be the
title that's the honest title you want
honesty in your titles he's a grave
robber robber who named himself after
his dog screw just an insane thing to do
right like call me by my dead dog's name
[Laughter]
wait I don't like how they what they do
to Salah or Marcus Brody either and they
make them both do folks is they're cool
characters in the first right there's
like a third not cool
but but the character yeah I mean look
the more we do these movies that are set
in like that were made in the early 80s
late 70s we're good I just have to talk
about brown face so the inevitable
short-circuit honest trailer is gonna be
know there's a guy in full the whatever
you want to call it in the in the bar
scene there's definitely a Mongolian
henchman who is not anyways Molina also
plays Satipo
the member of the local tribe and really
does I couldn't tell if they tried to
make yeah I couldn't tell in Raiders if
they trying to make you guys look
Mongolian or if he had a squib on his
face cuz he liked his face catches on
fire selling they had prosthetics on his
face so that he could burn but also
maybe both yeah well there you go
I mean look you've already seen these
movies y'all have your thoughts on on
the Indiana Jones films give them a
rewatch it's a good time I think that
you won't be it's it's it's time well
spent
there's they're fun they're super fun
there's there's uncomfortable moments
but what movie made before 2018
tene oh god don't go back even faster
mine we tried to the 2009 is also trash
so there you go that's that's all I have
to say about Indiana Jones I need any
parting thoughts any for anything we
didn't get to think we've whipped it we
whipped it we whipped it good so please
come back next week when we will discuss
the honest trailer for another film that
prominently shares an actor with the
Indiana Jones franchise that's a clue I
hope you hope you have fun until then
we'll see you next Tuesday I'm an acro
[Music]
you